JILLIAN: SET UP PARENT IN NEW
YORK CITY TAKING LEGAL ACTION TO
GET THEIR KIDS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM FULL TIME.
THEY SAY STUDENTS SUFFERING
UNDER THE CURRENT HYBRID SYSTEM
AND MAKING TO BE BACK IN SCHOOL.
NEW YORK CITY MOM LEADING THE
CHARGE JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I KNOW IT HAS BEEN A WHIRLWIND,
THERE HAS BEEN BACK AND FORTH
AND YOU AMONG MANY OTHERS ARE
COMPLETELY FRUSTRATED.
KIDS ARE SET TO RETURN TO SCHOOL
ON APRIL 20 SIXTH.
HOWEVER, I KNOW AN UPDATE FROM
PARENTS RECEIVING EMAILS TELLING
THEM THAT THE PURPOSE OF
EDUCATION IS PUTTING A 3 FOOT
RULE ON HOLD SO DO YOU KNOW DOES
THIS PUT THE APRIL 26TH THEY DO
IN JEOPARDY NOW?
>> APRIL 26TH IS THE DAY WHEN
51,000 STUDENTS WHO HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN FULLY REMOTE,
NEWLY OPTED IN STUDENTS ARE SET
TO RETURN.
THAT IS STILL HOLDING.
HOWEVER, ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS SENT
OUT EMAILS TO PARENTS TELLING US
THEY ADOPTED THE 3 FOOT RULE IN
THE CLASSROOM AND ALL KIDS IN
MOST SCHOOLS, NOT ALL SCHOOLS,
WOULD BE GOING FULL-TIME AT THE
SAME TIME AS THE NEW KIDS WOULD
RETURN ON APRIL 20 SIXTH.
LAST NIGHT WE GOT A FLURRY OF
TEXT EMAIL CALLS FROM PARENTS
WERE PANICKING BECAUSE THEIR
SCHOOLS SENT SOME EMAILS SAYING
THE 3 FOOT WAS ON HOLD, NO ONE
IS COMING BACK FULL TIME WE WILL
KEEP YOU UPDATED BUT THERE HAS
BEEN A HOLDUP WITH THE UNION.
THAT IS THE RUMOR.
I HAVEN’T GOTTEN CONFIRMATION.
>> PUT YOUR HEAD DOWN AND CRY
WHEN YOU GET THESE EMAILS AND
YOU SEE THIS.
YOU FEEL FOR YOUR KIDS WHO HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING.
IS THAT WHAT MADE YOU BECOME
SUCH A FORCE TO PUT YOUR FOOT
DOWN AND SAY I NEED TO FIGHT
LEGALLY?
>> YES BECAUSE WE ARE NOT SEEING
ANY ADVOCACY FOR THE CHILDREN ON
THE PART OF THE DOE AND CITY.
THEY ARE FAILING OUR CHILDREN,
WE ARE HOPING THEY ARE SEEING
THE URGENCY THE CHILDREN NEED TO
BE BACK IN SCHOOL, CRAZY
SCHEDULE UP AND DOWN, THE WILL
THAT WAS AROUND UP UNTIL A FEW
WEEKS AGO THAT WOULD SHUT DOWN
SCHOOLS FOR 10 DAYS WITH NO
SCIENTIFIC BASIS, SCHOOLS WOULD
GET SHUTDOWN FOR 5 TIMES, 50
DAYS IN SEPTEMBER.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT AND
WE CAN’T RELY ON THE MAYOR TO
LOOK TO SCIENCE FOR GUIDANCE ON
HOW TO BRING KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL
TIME.
ASHLEY: YOU HAVE TWO KIDS THAT
ARE YOUNG, 7, AND 10.
WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENCES YOU’VE
SEEN IN THE LAST YEAR?
>> NOT HAVING THE CONSISTENCY OF
THE SCHEDULE HAS BEEN SO
DISRUPTIVE IT IS HARD TO GET
THEM TO GO TO SLEEP AT NIGHT OR
TO WAKE UP IN THE MORNING.
MY 7-YEAR-OLD CRIES IT IS SO SAD
SHE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
ARE ALL THESE DAYS SHE CAN’T SEE
HER TEACHER, HER CLASS OR HER
FRIENDS, SOCIALIZATION HAS BEEN
IMPEDED IN A BIG WAY.
THE COLD WAR IS -- THERE AREN’T
THAT MANY KIDS IN THE CLASS TO
BEGIN WITH AND MANY OF THE KIDS
THEY KNOW ON ALTERNATE DAYS, IT
IS A STRANGE ENVIRONMENT.
I CALL IT THE NEW NORMAL, THEY
DON’T ACCEPT IT.
WE WANT THEM BACK FULL TIME
EVERY DAY.
PRE-K-12, WE ARE NOT TALKING
MENTAL OR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL,
MIDDLE OR HIGH SCHOOL, MIDDLE OR
HIGH SCHOOL ARE NOT COMING BACK
FULL TIME AND THERE’S NO CURRENT
PLANS TO ADOPT THREE FEET FOR
THEM SO WE ARE COMPLETELY
MISSING THOSE KIDS AND THEY ARE